[Musique]
dans la presse avec vous hélène frade
bien sûr bonjour hélène dans la presse
de ce mercredi les réactions
occidentales aux manoeuvres militaires
de la russie on en parlait à l'instant
avec julian calling à proximité de
l'ukraine et en crimée annexée ces
manoeuvres lancées au lendemain de la
mise en alerte de milliers de soldats
américains marque l'intensification
d'une crise qui menace la stabilité de
l'europe selon le temps où le dessin de
chappatte on le voit montre des soldats
postés à la frontière ukrainienne au
fait bonne année on dit que le 20 31
janvier c'est le dernier moment pour
faire ses voeux face à l' escalade sans
fin entre moscou et les occidentaux le
journal suisse s'inquiète de voir joe
biden affaiblie alors qu'un bras de fer
crucial l'oppose à vladimir poutine une
préoccupation partagée en france par le
figaro qui accuse les atermoiements du
président américain de saper la capacité
de dissuasion des occidentaux le camp
occidental dont les divergences s'étale
à la une de la presse internationale le
quotidien espagnol el país évoque même
l'affrontement entre washington et
bruxelles sur la stratégie à suivre pour
stopper la russie les etats-unis
nourrissant l'idée d'une agression
imminente tandis que l'europe
chercherait plutôt elle a relativisé le
danger la vanguardia quotidien catalan
fait état des tentatives de la france et
de l'allemagne pour engager une
désescalade par un dialogue avec la
russie avec notamment notre tient
téléphonique ce vendredi entre vladimir
poutine emmanuel macron qui a rappelé à
ceux qui déplorent la faiblesse de
l'europe que les discussions engagées
ces derniers mois par les états unis
n'ont pas eu non plus de résultats
concrets conscients que leurs
divergences constitue une faiblesse face
à la russie américains et européens
tentent ces dernières heures on l'a vu
un de montrer un front plus uni comme en
témoigne l'annoncé hier par washington
de la mise en place d'un plan de
détournement des approvisionnements en
gaz naturel du monde entier vers
l'europe au cas où les importations en
provenance de la russie serait coupé le
but de la manoeuvre étant de parvenir je
cite à émousser larmes économique la
plus puissante dont dispose la dîmière
possible la russie a appelé par ailleurs
à la rescousse par une partie des
burkinabés hélène après le coup d'état
militaire contre le désormais ex
président roch marc christian kaboré de
new york times rapporte que certains
burkinabè lassés par l'échec de leur
gouvernement et de la france à arrêter
les violences des djihadistes demande en
effet la russie d'intervenir le
quotidien fait état de témoignages de
manifestants se disant inspiré par
l'intervention de la russie en
république centrafricaine où les russes
assurent la sécurité du président ou les
entreprises russes exploite les mines de
diamant et où les mercenaires russes ont
repoussé l'année dernière une offensive
jihadistes d'autres manifestants
évoquent également l'incursion plus
récente de la russie au mali voisin
d'après le new york times la position
d'une web du nouvel homme fort du
burkina faso le lieutenant-colonel port
polhenri sandaogo damiba ne serait pas
clair mais le quotidien cite plusieurs
responsables américains qu'ils
estimeraient tout à fait plausible que
le nouveau pouvoir militaire demande
l'aide de la russie un mot pour terminer
du feuilleton partie gate on en parlait
dans le journal au royaume-uni dernier
épisode en date l'annoncé hier par la
police londonienne de l'ouverture d'une
enquête sur les fêtes organisées en
stricte pendant à les différents
confinement d'après le guardian la
cheffe de la m a déclaré que ces agents
enquêtent sur des allégations
d'infraction à la loi au sein du
gouvernement sur la base des preuves
mises au jour par une autre enquête
conduite elle par la haute fonctionnaire
sur gré boris johnson se prépare à
affronter les 48 heures les plus
périlleuses depuis qu'il occupe le poste
de premier ministre écrit le guardian
mais qui fait état de la façon pour le
moins étrange dont l'un des proches de
beaux jo a tenté de prendre sa défense
en expliquant que le chef du
gouvernement n'avait pas fêté son
anniversaire en plein confinement mais
qu'il avait été pris en embuscade avec
un gâteau je cite des propos qui ont
évidemment déclenché l'hilarité les
détournements sur les réseaux sociaux
comme ce tweet montrant boggio fois en
tenue de soldat tenue de combat pris en
embuscade donc par un gâteau ou cet
autre montrant la réaction supposée des
manuels macron et angela merkel à
l'histoire de la tacc dit du gansu
d'anniversaire
merci beaucoup hélène c'était la revue
de presse on retrouve très vite sur
l'antenne de france 24 et nous on se
retrouve dans un quart d'heure à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]